earlier today Robert Kelley was indicted
before at Cook County grand jury on ten
counts of aggravated criminal sexual
abuse involving four victims our Kelly
has been indicted on 10 counts of
aggravated criminal sexual abuse ET can
confirm can you describe the physical
abuse I think really talk about being
abused is like brings back memories the
charge has come just weeks after the
documentary surviving r.kelly spurred
Cook County State's Attorney Kim Fox to
make a public plea for any Kelly
accusers to come forward attorney
Michael avenatti said in a statement on
Twitter last week that he had given
Fox's office of VHS tape that allegedly
shows Kelly engaging in sex with an
underage girl he wrote quote this tape
which is clear is approximately 45
minutes in length and has never
previously been publicly disclosed or
until recently provided to law
enforcement avenatti is reportedly
representing an individual who he
describes as a whistleblower against
Kelly according to The Hollywood
Reporter he told the outlet quote my
client knows the identity of the girl
and our Kelly he identified the two of
them on the videotape he worked for and
has known our Kelly for decades and he
met the girl on a number of occasions
Kelly's attorney Stephen Greenberg has
adamantly and consistently denied all
allegations of wrongdoing and expressed
confidence that the singer will be
cleared of any possible charges this
marks the second time that Kelly has
been charged with a sex crime by Cook
County prosecutors prosecutors accused
the singer of child pornography but in
2008 a jury acquitted him of charges
alleging he filmed himself having sex
with an underage girl
[Music]